Hello everybody, welcome to this workshop on Wikidata for the University of Maastricht
on the 15th of October 2024. My name is Olaf, I'm the Wikimedia Coordinator at the National
Library of the Netherlands. And today, for the next two and a half hours, I will guide
this workshop on Wikidata related to professors here at Maastricht University. And this workshop
will be in two parts. It will be first a theoretical introduction where we will look at the basics
of Wikidata, so really the principles and founding guidances of Wikidata. And also in
the theoretical part we will look at how we can use Wikidata in research, science and
cultural heritage. That will be about an hour, so that will be me presenting the theory to
you. And of course, if you have any questions, you can send me an email or we can have a
chat if you would like to know more about that part of Wikidata. Then we have a short
break and after the break there will be a second theoretical part, so where you will actually try
to make your first edits and contributions to Wikidata, themed by data on professors of
Maastricht University. For the second part, there's actually a separate video available which
you will find on the page this video is in. I recorded it also today when it was still daylight.
So if you want to work through that workshop, the practical part of the workshop yourself,
then you can go and check out that video. And the second part is between 75 or 90 minutes,
but for this particular video that I'm recording now, I will actually only do the basics of Wikidata,
so that will be approximately an hour of video you will have had. So let me go on to the opening
slide of this theoretical part. As I said, I'm Olaf Janssen, I'm with the National Library of
the Netherlands. And for the next hour, we will look at the basics of Wikidata. So what Wikidata
is, what are the principles of Wikidata, both from the technical and social point of view,
and with social, I mean the community point of view. And then in the second part of this first
theoretical block, I will show you some case studies on how Wikidata can be relevant for
the domains of research, science and cultural heritage. Perhaps a small introduction about
myself. As I said, I'm with the National Library of the Netherlands, and I'm the Wikimedia
Coordinator of our library. And in that role, which I've been fulfilling for 10 years now,
I try to bring two worlds together. On the one hand, there is the world of the KB with our
collections and our data and our books, of course, and our information and our people.
And on the other hand, there is the world of Wikipedia, for instance, Encyclopedia, but also
projects like Wikidata that we'll discuss today, or the image repository of Wikipedia called
Wikimedia Commons. And the volunteers of creators, or sorry, the communities of creators, mostly
volunteers, that work on these platforms to sustain them and to grow them. In these two worlds,
I try to collaborate them together to mutual benefit. For instance, we as the KB take a lot
of information from Wikipedia, Wikidata, but also make sure that we contribute to Wikidata. And one
of the contributions that we also do, it's not only adding data to Wikidata, but also educating
other heritage institutions and other universities about Wikidata. This is exactly the thing that I'm
doing right now. So I'm sharing my knowledge with you and hopefully the wider Wikimedia community
just for mutual benefit, so to say. All right, so what do I hope that you will have
learned or gained some more understanding of by the end of this afternoon? First of all,
that you have a basic idea of what Wikidata is, how it works, both from the technical perspective,
like the data perspective, and also from the community slash social perspective. So that you
will also have a little insight in how the community around Wikidata is organized.
Because I put it here on purpose, because in many introductory talks about Wikidata,
it only focuses on this real hard data aspect of Wikidata. But for me, the community aspects are
equally important, actually. And actually, I think they're even more important than the technical
aspects of Wikidata. And why I think so, I will discuss later on in this presentation.
Then next, the second learning goal is trying to give you a small insight into how Wikidata can be
relevant for research, science, and cultural heritage. And then lastly, and this is the second
part of the workshop, the practical part, for which a separate video is available also, is trying to
guide you through making your first steps into Wikidata yourself. So doing your first contributions
focused on data of professors here at Maastricht University. So let's start simply by asking
ourselves, what is Wikidata? Well, if you talk with people about Wikidata, you get a wide variety
of answers. But depending on their view on Wikidata and their level of experience with
Wikidata, I think the most basic thing you can explain about Wikidata is that it is a database
containing structured descriptions of all sorts of things. And what kinds of things are,
can you think of, for instance, it as a description, a structured description of the Eiffel Tower,
or this valley in Antarctica, or this hit single by Girlfriend, or this book, or this American judge,
or this airport in the United States, or this gene, or this election in Catalonia,
or this scientific article, or this species of insect, or this composition by Robert Schumann,
or this street in the Netherlands, or this family name, or this quasar in the constellation of
Urza Meyer, or this really nice car, or this really nice metal band, or this international
football association, or this cannabis seed bank in Canada, or this researcher, or this randomly
chosen library from the Netherlands. So you see there are a lot of different things described in
Wikidata. In total, when I last checked it, nearly 114 million distinct things are described in
Wikidata. To give you just a short glimpse of what kind of groups together, like classes,
there are described in Wikidata. It has a lot of scientific articles to start with. This is the
the green pie chart. I will come back to that towards the end of my presentation, why it is
such a big chunk. But also there are roughly some 5 million people, 5 to 6 million people described
in Wikidata, animal and plants, etc. Chemical substances, thousands and thousands of
astronomical objects, genes, really a lot of genes are available in Wikidata, etc.
So Wikidata is both very broad, but it can also be very specific, like it has
currently nearly 900 descriptions of Van Gogh paintings.
If you take all the things in Wikidata that have geographical coordinates, like longitude
and latitude, and you plot them on a map, you get this map, which was last created a year ago.
Basically, this is a map of where people live, because where people live, they tend to describe
their things in their surroundings. And it's typically along the coast. You will see,
for instance, also this kind of map with other data points related to human civilization and
where humans live. Okay, so that was a really brief introduction into Wikidata, really basic.
What I would like to do next in the second part of the talk is to have a look at the principles
that are guiding Wikidata. And those are seven. And let me just start by the first one.
Wikidata contains structured descriptions of things. You can think, for instance, about
Wikipedia. Wikipedia also contains descriptions of things, but those descriptions are free text.
So they are not structured. And what do I mean by structured? It's the following, like there is,
for instance, the Eiffel Tower is described in Wikidata. And you can see here that the Eiffel
Tower is named after Gustave Eiffel. And it is situated in the country of France. And it is the
property of the government of France. And these are structured descriptions. So it's a
thing, the Eiffel Tower, and it has this property, which has a value here. And in this way,
the entire Wikidata item is structured. What you notice here is that this description of the Eiffel
Tower is in English. All the fields that you see here, all these strings and all these
things here, those are all in English. Why that's important, you will find out in a moment.
Then secondly, all these 114 million descriptions are stored in one big central system. At least
for the user, that is the experience. Behind the scenes, I think there will be multiple databases
working together. But for the user experience, it's one big storage of data. And data is not
available only in English, but in over 200 different languages. And that's why I just
showed you the English interface. You can also trigger the Dutch interface of Wikidata. And then
you will see all these texts here. Those are all in Dutch. You can also do it in Portuguese,
and even in Japanese. Most of the items here are also available in Japanese, as you can see here.
All right, that was the first three. The fourth thing is that on Wikidata, that it contains
linked data. And how do I explain this? The phrase that you use is linked data is about
things, not strings. And it is made clear by looking at, for instance,
after whom the Eiffel Tower was named, being Gustav Eiffel. And this text you see here,
Gustav Eiffel, that's not plain text, but it's actually a URL you can click on. It's a clickable
link. And when you click on this link, you will go to the Wikidata item on Gustav Eiffel. And in
Gustav Eiffel, there are the other blue links, as you can see here, that use a human, etc. You can
also click on those, and then you'll go to the Wikidata items on, in this case, human.
This is meant by, so these are all entities in semantic terms, and not just ordinary strings.
These are mutually interconnected, as will be clear from this example. So there are like a
billion and billions of connections between all the items in Wikidata. So it's strongly internally
connected. But also Wikidata is strongly connected to the outside world, because in this case, for
the Eiffel Tower, these are all databases you see here, in which the Eiffel Tower is also described.
And if you, for instance, look at this one, the Skyscraper Center Building ID, and if you click
on this identifier in that particular database, you will get a description of the Eiffel Tower
in this database. Currently, there are over 9,000 different databases known to Wikidata.
So in theory, it's not the case, but provided they would all have an item on the Eiffel Tower,
this list of external databases would be 9,000 rows long. But that's just an illustration of
how many databases are actually available in Wikidata.
Okay, number five, Wikidata is free and open. And what do I mean by free? Free is as in gratis,
as in you don't have to pay money for it. And open is free. So you can go to the website,
pay money for it, to access it. Also, there are no trackers, like cookies and stuff in Wikidata.
And you will never see an ad that you have to avoid or click on. Because Wikidata is actually
under the same funding as Wikipedia. It's financed by getting annual donations from
about 7 million people from all over the world. Also, what is also defined by the word open here
is that the fact that in Wikidata, all the data is free of copyright and also free of database rights.
And that's because all the data in Wikidata is under the CC0 license. Effectively, this means
that all the data is dedicated into the public domain. This has two big consequences, this
principle that it is open. First of all, everybody is allowed to reuse the data in Wikidata. So you
can search it, you can share it, you can copy data, you can actually download all of Wikidata
and sell that as a commercial product. That's fully allowed because it's all in the public domain.
Secondly, the open nature of Wikidata also means that everybody can contribute data. Everybody can
add data, everybody can improve data, they can join two similar items, they can delete items, they can
add other kinds of information to Wikidata. And if you think that's true, there are actually a lot of
people that like doing that. Personally, I'm quite fond of adding new data to Wikidata.
And I'm not the only one in the world, because there is a strong Wikidata community.
And there are about 23,000 people on the planet that work on Wikidata at least once a week,
that's meant by active contributors. Of which I am one. So I have, you could also say that I have
23,000 colleagues all over the world, which I can reach out to if I need any help, or if I can,
if I also can give knowledge and my time and my knowledge about Wikidata, I can give them to them.
And what you also see on the background, I will come back to this later in a bit more detail,
but these people, they really like to meet each other, because I think every week or so, and
perhaps more often, somewhere in the world, there is a gathering of people working on Wikidata.
So this is an international bunch of people, really ranging from here, this is the Netherlands,
this was in Haiti, this was in Nigeria, if I remember correctly, this was in Nepal, I guess.
So a really international crowd, and I think the community is the unique selling point of Wikidata.
And why do I think so? In the previous slide I told that you can, in principle, you can download
Wikidata fully, the full database, and you can try to build a commercial product around it.
That's actually, I guess, not a totally unachievable task, it's a doable effort,
but what you don't, what you can't buy with money is the commitment and the time and the enthusiasm
and even the love of people for Wikidata. You can't buy these 23,000 people to actually come
and work at your new commercial version of Wikidata. And this is actually, I think, the
unique part of Wikidata, that there is this community that is really enthusiastic about
Wikidata, is helping each other all the time, it's global, it's very open, very friendly people,
which money simply can't buy. And more about the Wikidata community later in this presentation.
Okay, and the final guiding principle of Wikidata is number seven. This has to do with the fact that
Wikidata is both for humans. You can have, as a human, you can have an interaction with Wikidata
via the web interface of Wikidata. So you can read this stuff, but you can also change it and edit it,
and you can merge it, etc. And all these kind of operations you can do via the graphical user
interface, typically associated with HTML. But if you're a machine, or if somebody actually writes
a script to have machine interaction with Wikidata, that's also fully possible, because all
the things you can do via the graphical user interface, you can also do via a set of APIs.
So these are actually fully equivalent. If you can, everything you can do here, you can also do
programmatically via the API. All right, so far for the first two items on the agenda of this
theoretical part. What I would like to do next is to have a look at how things are actually
described in Wikidata. All right, so let's look at how things are described in Wikidata.
And this is always the classical image that is also available on the front page of the Wikidata
website. To illustrate this principle, we have this thing, in this case the Earth, and this has this
property, in this case the highest point. And this property has a value, and in this case it's
Mount Everest. And in Wikidata terms, it goes as follows. The Earth, which is Q2, and this Q-number
in Wikidata, that's a unique identifier of the thing that is being described. So apparently,
the Earth was the second thing ever to be described in Wikidata. Q1 is the universe, Q42 is
Douglas Adams, of course, all the way up to Q114 million at the moment. And this is just a number
that goes up every time a new Wikidata item is created. This Q2 has this property, highest point.
So this is this Q2 thing again, sorry. And this has this highest point, which is a property
in Wikidata, denoted by the P-number here. And this is apparently the 610th property that was
ever recorded in Wikidata. And the value of the thing is here, the Q-number for Mount Everest,
actually hidden by my little camera here. But this is, I can't read the Q-number actually,
but this is a Q-number. So it's always Q-P-Q, hence the Q, so like this,
actually the classical semantical triple. So let's illustrate that a bit further by looking at
the item of the KB in Wikidata. And the KB has this unique identifier. So that is the
unique Q-number by which the National Library of Netherlands is identified.
And this block on top, that's called the fingerprint in Wikidata terms.
This is multilingual. As you can see, there is a description in English, in German, in Spanish,
etc., also in Dutch, of course. And this has these fields of a label. So this is the title of the
item. And this is also reflected here. So if I were to change this, then this would change.
A little description, so a short characterization of what the thing is. This is the National
Library of the Netherlands. And here are these aliases, also known as alternative names,
by which this particular item is known, like the KB or the Royal Library, etc.
Next, if you scroll down that item page, then you will see that there is a claim made about
the country in which the National Library is. So this is again the same Q-P-Q triple. So it's
the KB, Q-number, this number. The country is identified by property 17 in Wikidata.
And the value of this property is it's in the Netherlands, which has number Q55.
And the place where this information comes from, the source reference, is listed as in this block.
This is called the reference. And it says, well, the claim that the KB is in the Netherlands is
drawn from this website, which was published in December 2019.
And this information was retrieved on this, the 12th of December,
2021. Everything that is in Wikidata should have a source reference. You can also see it here,
for instance, this claim has a reference, this has a reference, this not yet. But if you're
working on Wikidata, always try to add references to where you found the information that is being
given in the item. Then if you scroll down, you will see that there is a claim that the
KB is a member of a range of library associations. And if you look at this one, it's the KB is a member of the Conference of European National Librarians.
And in this bit, point in time 2022, so this claim was true in this year, this refinement,
that's called a qualifier. So qualifier is always the thing that refines the
how do you call that? The upper general, more general statement.
And finally, there is a list of external identifiers, just the same as I showed you with
the Eiffel Tower. And so these are all claims about the National Library. Okay, I actually
already mentioned that currently there are 9,000 over 9,000, to be said 9,045 different databases
known to Wikidata. And all these databases have their own properties. As you can see here,
these are all P numbers. So these all have their own properties. And actually, this is one of the
major functions of Wikidata is to be a hub on the internet to connect all kinds of databases
together. And I don't know any other registry or any other big place where so many different
databases are recorded. So if you want to discover obscure databases that you will never have heard
of before, Wikidata is the place to go to. If you just go to this and you check them out, you will
be amazed what kind of data is recorded in the world. And if you want to check out this information
in a bit more relaxed or laid-back manner, you can go to this page. This is a page on the
simplified data model of Wikidata. Basically, here is the same information as I just explained
to you is available, but you can read it at your own pace. And one thing I need to point out is
the following, that Wikidata has a version history. And this means that every edit that is stored
is stored forever. So everything you do in Wikidata is recorded. And you can always go back to previous
versions of the document and make sure that you don't put anything in Wikidata that is private
or secret. Because once it's in Wikidata, it is public forever. So be careful about what you add
to Wikidata. All right. Now let's look at some examples of what kind of information can be
requested from Wikidata. And I'm going to build it on three slides we saw before. The fact that
all the data in Wikidata is stored centrally. That it has all kinds of things, Wikidata,
and that everything is interconnected. Those three things, if you combine them together,
centrally stored, all sorts of things and everything is connected, you can ask really
interesting questions to Wikidata. If you want to ask questions to Wikidata, you do that via
a search language which is called SPARQL. It's like a dialect of SQL. And this is a common search
language for linked open databases. I'm not going to go into detail on SPARQL. That's an entire
day in itself, I guess. I can give workshops and lectures on that as well. But it's far
beyond the scope of this introductory workshop we're doing at the moment. But what I would like
to do now is to look at some results that you can get from SPARQLing in Wikidata. For instance,
you can ask Wikidata, give me some depictions of house cats and you will get up this result.
And if you click on this link, it will trigger this gallery, this depiction gallery.
You can also ask Wikidata, give me a list of things that are named after French presidents,
but which are outside of France. And you will, for instance, discover that in
Ivory Coast, apparently there is a bridge named after General De Gaulle. You can really make
interesting discoveries. And in Poland, there's also a roundabout called, of course, named after
Charles De Gaulle, etc. Or you can ask, give me a list of the causes of death of American presidents.
Or you can say, man, Nobel Prizes were awarded last week. And I wanted to know, well, who were
Dutch people that were nominated for a Nobel Prize, but actually never won the prize?
You get this list and you see that the Dutch author of Simon Vesdijk, he was nominated 11
times for the Nobel Prize, but he never won it. That's quite sad. But if you think,
Simon Vesdijk is a sad guy, think again, because this guy, Johannes Willem Sommerfeld,
he was nominated no fewer than 84 times for the Nobel Prize, but he never won it. And, yeah,
the cruel thing is that all of his PhD students, of like, like, 10, I believe 10 or so of his PhD
students, were actually winners of Nobel Prizes. But the man himself never won it, I'm afraid.
This is also a really nice query to show you the power of Wikidata paintings with alliterative
titles. I think about, for instance, like, what was it, an Apollo artist,
Cesar Chechime, so all alliterations.
10 largest cities with female mayors, you can also request that these are the cities,
these are the populations, and these are the female mayors. And finally, you can request a list
of birthplaces of economists that already died, divided by time period. So these are the time
periods, and the different colors represent each one, one time period here. And these are the
places where these economists, these already deceased economists were actually born.
Okay, this is to show you the power of Wikidata, basically. And now for the next block,
I would like to look at the things we saw before, all quite, let's call it more technical,
more data aspects of Wikidata. And I would like to have a also look at the social slash community
aspects of Wikidata. And this, if you ask this question, who builds Wikidata?
Then the answer is the community, because it's a community project.
And here on this slide, you see a roughly 1% of all the people in the world that's working
on Wikidata. And what I already told actually is that there are currently 23,000 active contributors
to Wikidata. And it has been in existence since October 2012. So currently we're celebrating the
12th birthday of Wikidata. And since that time, they have made 2.25 billion edits, which is an
awful lot. These people don't only like to work on Wikidata as a data thing, but they also,
as you can see from this group, they like to meet each other. And when you become active
in the Wikidata community, as I said, you like to meet each other, but you also will,
by experience, be drawn to certain roles or certain tasks within the community
that you like more than others. And here you can see a number of roles that are
present in the Wikidata community. It can be a developer, or it can be an ambassador,
or it can be a translator. And when you look at a somewhat larger list of different roles you can
fulfill within the community, you will see that there are, this is not a hard division, but
I try to group the more hard data roles, like being a developer, or data editor, or data modeler,
or a SPARQL expert, here above the line here. But the nice thing about Wikidata is also that there
are lots of roles you can have in the community that are not really about hard data, but like,
you can translate in data in Wikidata, or you can be an event organizer. So all these events that
take place all over the world with subgroups of the Wikidata community, these are all organized
by those people themselves. So you can also, if you like organizing events, you can become a member
of the Wikidata community. Or you can do communication and outreach, or what I'm doing right now at this
moment, I can be a teacher, a trainer, and a speaker. This is also a role you can have
in the Wikidata community. So for every type of job role, there's always a place for you within
Wikidata. And another thing to shed another light on the community is the following. I asked
ChatGPT last week, what can you tell me about the mindset behind the Wikidata community?
And it came up with this really great answer. This was spot on, so I just copied it. I didn't
try to paraphrase it in any way. It's all about openness and transparency. It's about
collaboration and collective intelligence, the wisdom of the crowd here. It's about inclusivity
and diversity. Everybody is welcome from all over the world, independent of country, sexual
preference, education, etc. You're all very welcome, independent of culture, language,
expertise, etc. It's all about innovation and experimentation. It's about a strong culture of
experimentation, which is exactly how I personally like to work. I like to experiment with stuff.
It's about supportive collective learning, and it's about having an impact on the entire planet.
It's a global database. It's a global project. And this is also in the mind of people working
on Wikidata, that you're not doing this for your own institution or your own country even, but it's
really geared towards the entire world. This also means, this community sense, is that people like
to meet each other, as I already said, and it really happens all over the world. These are all
images of celebrations of Wikidata birthdays in the past, and you see it's from Indonesia, India,
Nepal, Germany, Netherlands, Turkey, etc. So it's a really global community.
Once every year, on average, there is this big international meetup of people that like Wikidata.
This is called WikidataCon. And here you can meet people from all over the world that are
working and are enthusiastic about Wikidata. And one of the events that takes place right now,
this month, is the birthday celebration of Wikidata. Currently we do the 12th birthday.
And people, they come together, they really celebrate Wikidata, they bake cakes with the
Wikidata logo on it, and they have their favorite t-shirts on. And it's really, you see, quite
literally all over the world, Wikidata is being celebrated. Also, throughout the year, many
Wikidata workshops are giving, introduction workshops, as I'm doing at the moment here right now,
but also more advanced workshops are also given, or more specialized technical meetups,
like hackathons and editathons, they're also happening quite often. And as a good community,
of course, you have your community swag, you have your t-shirts and your caps and your
breadcases and your brooms and your pens, etc. And this is me personally wearing my Wikidata t-shirts,
etc. It says stickers, of course, to put on your laptops. This is also a manifestation of the
fandom that many people have about Wikidata. So I hope this little section gave you some feeling
of the human side of Wikidata, I think I call it that way, the social and community aspects
which makes Wikidata such a nice place. Okay, then I've arrived at the last part of my,
this particular presentation, this talk. And this talk, this part is to do with
illustrating how Wikidata can be relevant for research, science and cultural heritage.
And this is actually a section I made especially for this workshop, this lecture.
So let's find out what it is. I think this section will take about 15 to 20 minutes.
So then we'll have a full hour of presentation done. This is not much time, 15 to 20 minutes is
not a lot of time to actually talk about this topic. So as you will see, this section will be
quite anecdotic. It's not a concise treatment of all the various aspects of Wikidata has
in relation to research, science and cultural heritage. But it's like, I will bring forward
a number of use cases which hopefully will illustrate this sentence here in a nice way.
And when I was thinking how shall I introduce this part of the presentation,
I thought the following. My line of thought was as follows. In this slide that we saw before,
you see actually that Wikidata holds data about many fields of science and research,
like chemistry, astronomy, genetic sciences, scientific articles, biology and stuff,
and et cetera here. And what I thought, well, actually, I don't need to talk about
what Wikidata holds for science, but the other way around, what science holds for Wikidata.
So I looked up a visual representation of all of human knowledge. These are all fields of
human knowledge, as you can see. And I asked myself the question, to what extent is Wikidata
used throughout science research and GLAM / cultural heritage? And actually,
I didn't have an immediate answer to that. So I tried searching academic databases,
looking for articles on Wikidata, and then plot them on certain fields of knowledge.
And this was not immediately an easy exercise until I found this website. You can see here at
the very bottom of the slide, it's called SemanticScholar.org. This is a service that you can
search over 200 million scientific articles with. And if you do this query, you can look for
articles that are related to Wikidata. And the nice thing about SemanticScholar is that you can
filter on fields of study. And this is what I did to get an overview of this. And then I found out
that Wikidata is used in the area of gender studies, and also on history and linguistics,
and geography and sociology and information science, art, astronomy, biology and microbiology,
computer science, medicine, environmental sciences, and even in ecology.
So it's certainly not a full, not every domain of human knowledge is represented via Wikidata,
but quite a few. And I also think that increasingly, because I think if you did
that exercise 10 years ago, you would have far less white bins here. So increasingly,
you Wikidata shows its relevance for increasingly more fields of knowledge.
And what I would like to do now is to look at six case studies, six anecdotal cases. And
there's a little point, of course, I did it anecdotally, because it's about Wikidata.
And look at six use cases, which hopefully show or at least illustrate
how Wikidata can be relevant for that particular field of science.
And the first case study, the first case I would like to bring forward has to do with
the field of scholarly communication or scientometrics. And scientometrics is the
quantitative study of science and scientific communication. So for instance, if you want to
know who is the most cited author in a certain field of science, or the most prolific journals
in a certain field, that's the things that are being studied in scientometrics.
And a really nice scientometric tool is Scholia. And what's Scholia? Scholia is a service that
creates visual scholarly profiles for researchers, articles, organizations, etc.,
all based on information from Wikidata. And I need to illustrate this, of course,
otherwise it will be a bit abstract. And the first profile that I would like to show you is
the profile from this professor here at Maastricht University, Gerard van Breukelen.
And this is a Scholia profile of Gerard. And if you go to this profile, what kind of things will
you actually encounter? First of all, there's a list of publications. So where he was the author
or one of the co-authors of the article. I have to be specific, these are not necessarily
all the articles that Gerard published, because these are only the articles that are recorded
in Wikidata. And I'm not sure if Wikidata has a complete inventory of all of his articles.
But for the articles that are available, you can make this list. You can also make this plot,
like how many articles he published over the years, either as the main author or one of the
co-authors or as a lower rank author. You can see by this, how I call it, bubble chart,
it's called what kind of research topics Gerard van Breukelen is involved in, and also in which
journals he published most. The bigger ones are the most often, I'm sorry, the journals he used
most often for his publications, and the smaller ones are the less used journals.
This is a graph of the co-authors, so the people who Gerard van Breukelen collaborated with in
writing his articles. And you can also see where these co-authors work across the globe by this
co-author map. And finally, you can also check out which articles by Gerard van Breukelen were
cited most often. And apparently this ANCOPA paper was cited 206 times. And of course,
you can also give the number of citations over the years. So this is how such a profile on
Scholia is composed. And the nice thing about Scholia is that you cannot only request these
profiles for authors, for people, but also for organizations or for articles or for journals or
for topics like obesity or for taxons like the Mosasaurus or chemical elements. These are all
possible, so you can have all these really nice ways to have various facets and spotlights on all
sorts of, let's say, classes of information. If you want to read more about Scholia, I can
recommend the base paper of Scholia where the project is introduced.
This one. And if you want to read on Wikidata about Scholia, you can go to the Scholia page on Wikidata.
Okay, the second one, the second field of science and research I would like to bring forward is
life and biomedical sciences. And I'm mainly doing this because the author of this particular paper,
Andra Waagmeester, is also a very active community member of Wikidata. So I know him
more from the Wikidata community than from this particular field. And I must be honest, I'm a bit
anxious. I'm holding my horses, let's say. I'm a bit anxious. That's too strong. But I'm not
very familiar in this field of knowledge. So I'm not going to talk about this in too much detail.
But what I would like to forward is that in this paper,
Wikidata is being discussed as a knowledge graph for the life sciences. And this paper demonstrates
several use cases of Wikidata, including crowdsource creation of biomedical ontologies,
phenotype-based diagnosis of disease. I have no idea what this means, but I'll just take it for
granted that some of you might know it. And drug repurposing. And if you want to read the full
article, of course, you can go here. Another article by Andra Waagmeester is this one. This
has to do with aligning knowledge surrounding corona viruses. When the pandemic struck,
it said here that there were a lot of projects and initiatives that rose up in the beta corner.
And these were all very loosely related. And there was a need to have a common ground to bring
together all these different projects. And in this paper, Wikidata is suggested as such a common
ground. So this is used to make data sources related to human corona viruses more interoperable.
So these are two papers by Andra Waagmeester. Actually, he took it a step further and he did
a PhD on biomedical sciences and Wikidata. Not exactly, but this PhD of his, which he defended
successfully earlier this year in January, it has a lot of Wikidata in it. I counted it and it has
415 mentions of Wikidata. I think this is the most Wikidata dense PhD thesis, perhaps,
for sure in this field of science. And I think perhaps in the Netherlands, perhaps even worldwide,
this is Wikidata is very prominent in this particular PhD.
This is another article on biological taxonomy. For reasons of time, I'm not going to
detail it. I'm not going to talk about it. Actually, I'm just showing it to you.
Of course, this presentation is also available as a PowerPoint and as a PDF file. And there's also a
full text version of this presentation where you can find the link to this particular article.
If you want to study it yourself, you can do it after this presentation.
And then the third field that I would like to bring forward is this one,
astronomy. And this is, let's say, the mirror opposite of life sciences, because
that's actually the topic I studied. I studied astronomy in the 90s in Leiden.
So I'm much more familiar with the type of information you see here than the type of
information you saw on the previous slides. So I was really happy to find a paper that mentions
Wikidata in relation to astronomy. And this paper talks about using Wikidata to disambiguate
planetary features. And what are planetary features? Excuse me, in this context.
Think, for instance, of craters on the moon and craters on Mars that carry the same name.
So if you have a paper, if you have an astronomical publication, and you want to do
named entity recognition on that paper, and you would encounter, for instance, I think it's called
Adams here, the crater is called Adams, you're not sure if that crater is situated on the moon,
or if it's situated on Mars. To make that process easier, this paper suggests that Wikidata can be
used for extracting planetary names, and to make that named entity recognition process and this
disambiguation process of planetary features more easily.
Another thing about astronomy, this is also, I'm just going to show you this, I'm not going to
discuss it, but you can study it yourself afterwards if you're interested.
Because I would like to move on to the next, the fourth case study on using Wikidata.
And this has to do with a very hot topic at the moment, large language models and
artificial intelligence. And this paper talks about using Wikidata to make large language
models more accurate and flexible. Here it says that all the facts that are stated in Wikidata,
some 12 billion, they can be used to train large language models to provide more accurate answers.
And the other way around is also true. This paper talks about using artificial intelligence and LLMs
to improve the contents of Wikidata. And you might notice in Wikidata that some fields are empty,
for instance, that not all fields have been fulfilled, or that certain languages in Wikidata
are underrepresented. And this paper suggests that artificial intelligence could build,
could fill those kinds of current gaps. This is another paper on AI and LLMs related to Wikidata,
but as with the previous two other papers that I skipped, I will also skip this one
for reasons of time. So if you're interested in that, yeah, you can study it yourself.
Because what I would like to spend the last five remaining minutes on of this talk is this one.
This is a case study from my own library, from the KB. And this has to do with GLAM and cultural
heritage. And the thing about the KB is that we have this really nice collection of what we call
our collection highlights. We have really wonderful manuscripts and old atlases and these really
lovely, hand-illustrated books about birds of the Netherlands from the 18th century, basically.
And we have about 80 of these most beautiful and important objects of our collection.
These are our collection highlights. And these are all part of our national heritage.
And when you look at the way that we make these collection highlights available through our own
websites, like our own KB website, but also our catalog, and the way we show the fully digitized
works, you will notice that they are really good to look at and to read. You can, for instance,
read about all these collection highlights on our own websites. You can all find them in our catalogs.
And we have these books you can leaf through with all the digitized images of all these
80 collection highlights. And the metaphor is that you can view them and you can see them and
you can read them, but you can't touch them. And what do I mean by you can't touch them?
Is that if you actually want to build stuff, you want to use these collection highlights as
building blocks, if you want to create something from these collection highlights, then our own
web services are not very suitable. And what do we have to think? If I say build stuff,
then like you say you want to make visualizations based on our collection highlights, or you want
to build apps that contain collection highlights, or you want to make data stories, or you want to
do AI stuff, or you want to build tools, etc. or games you want to use, you want to make a game
of our collection highlights, or offline you want to do a publication, or you want to do an artwork
on these collection highlights, then our own website and our own catalog are not really
suitable for that. It's not a place that offers building blocks. So if you think that idea through,
what you actually would like to have is something like that. You would like your collections
highlights to be some kind of a technical Lego set that contains building blocks with which you
can make all these things I just showed you. And if you look at this slide, it's no coincidence
that this Lego box is powered by Wikidata and also Commons and Wikipedia.
And how do you need to see this? This is about what I've called Wikifying our collection highlights.
So what we made sure we did a project on that in 2020. And we made sure that our collection
highlights were all described on Wikidata. And also subsets or deeper level Wikidata items
regarding those highlights were made. Next, we made sure that all the 11,000 images we had
from our KB collection highlights were available on Wikimedia Commons. And we made sure that most
highlights got Wikipedia articles. And I've summarized that process of turning our collection
highlights into Wiki building blocks. I call that Wikifying. And once you start Wikifying your
collections, then you will be able, you will get all kinds of new functionalities that you
can now do with your collection highlights that were not possible before.
Perhaps this is a bit abstract, but I invite you to read a five series paper that I wrote about this.
50 cool things that you can now do with KB collection highlights. And these, the first part
is a general introduction for why we did the project and how we Wikified our collection highlights.
And then in the four next episodes of this series, in roughly, let's say 12 new functionalities per
article, you can discover what kind of new things we can now do with our collection highlights,
because our collection highlights are now available in the Wikimedia infrastructure.
This is a really nice article that I really would like to encourage you to read it.
And then the last example that I would like to show you
is this one. This is from the American Physical Society. So that's the
organization that supports physicists in the United States. And they provide these trainings
that aim at elevating the achievements of women and other underrepresented groups via Wikipedia
and via Wikidata. The American Physical Society has such an initiative.
A similar initiative is done by the Smithsonian Institutions in Washington.
And they want to improve the representation of women in science, technology, engineering and math
by working on Wikipedia articles to improve those and create those for more female scientists
and also do that simultaneously on Wikidata. And if you get better information in Wikipedia,
you get better info boxes. Here this is a Wikipedia info box. And then in Google search results,
which is based on this info box, the information here will also be visible better.
So by working on Wikidata and Wikipedia, eventually Google will also be improved.
And if you want to read more about this, these were just six case studies where I highlighted
a number of papers. If you want to read more papers on science and Wikidata, you can go to
the little list I compiled here for you. It's various Google Scholar and Semantic Scholar that
I talked about before. And you can look for Wikidata articles yourself. Okay, this is pretty
much the end of my talk. Nearly finished. What I would like to show you before I really finish is
where you can find this presentation on Zenodo. If you go to this record on Zenodo,
then you can either download this presentation as a PowerPoint or a PDF.
And if you want to discover Wikidata further, because I was only able to show you a really
small part actually of all the knowledge related to Wikidata, you can go to this page on GitHub,
the Wikidata General Overview. And this is kind of a comprehensive introduction into Wikidata,
but quite compact. I tried to squeeze as much information on the basic level about Wikidata
into a big list. It's a big inventory of mainly links to other places for Wikidata.
I think this is a really good general introduction, general overview of Wikidata if you're relatively
new to Wikidata. Okay, that was my presentation. That was my talk. Thank you for your attention.
If you have any questions or any suggestions, please reach out to me. The preferred way is via
email here. This is my email address at the National Library. You can find all the information
here on Zenodo. And I would like to know if you send me an email. If you want to know more, we can
get in contact further. Okay, that was it for me. Bye bye. And I'll see you in the second part of
the presentation, or the second part of the workshop, which is the practical, hands-on part
of the workshop. And this is available in a separate video, which is also available from
Zenodo in due time. Bye bye.